so the last time we did this was october
of 2017 when we shut down the channel
and we were gone for three months and at
the time i think we had 450 000
subscribers and then we came back and
then the interviews came back a bunch of
new shows came out and then it took off
to 3.2 million subs and we're gonna have
to shut it down again for a few
different reasons which i'll give you
the explanation why that is because i
feel like we've been on this journey
together you have no idea how much i get
energy i just yesterday i called 10 of
you to have a conversation with your
random calls couple of you guys posted a
video online i enjoy talking to i love
hearing the stories of people winning i
enjoy seeing people around the world
that are starting businesses and they're
life changing completely i love those of
you that love the interviews of
valuetainment whether it's the
motivation monday the how-to the special
projects that we do all of that
energizes me when we talk to each other
about what we've done together with
valuetainment however let me explain to
you why we're doing this so originally
when we started valuetainment it was
called patrick david just a youtube
channel mario and i started it and you
know 50 hundred subscribers first year
maybe a thousand second year and then
eventually we got to 20 000 and a
hundred thousand we couldn't believe it
and then a million 3.2 million and it's
continued towards that today but at this
point of the game it just had my fourth
baby we just moved to florida we just
bought two buildings that one of them is
going to be a studio potentially and the
other one real cool announcements will
make you on whatever one of them we're
going to do which you're going to like
but one of them is going to be the
headquarters and it's a whole building
you'll come and see the logo there we're
hiring people aggressively right now
both people in front of the camera and
behind the camera so there's a lot of
things going on i'm still a full-time
ceo for multiple companies there's a lot
of projects i'll keep it at that mafia
states of america many other projects
that we're working on but this is what
i'm most excited about this thing went
from a small idea of
two minutes with pat's show the first
one to a few other episodes we were
doing today we changed it to vitamin to
then we bought the domain vitamin.com
from a publicly traded company to now
becoming a media company and eventually
a network and ott side competing with
some of the biggest networks and media
companies out there very very excited
about this this whole concept about
capitalism entrepreneurship curiosity
about wanting to learn more and go a
little bit deeper into the topics that
is not going away all i'm saying to you
is moving forward motivation monday
you're not going to see any for a while
how to tuesdays business episodes it's
not going to happen for a while my
bandwidth simply doesn't allow me to you
are going to see a few interviews that i
still have done that's going to go live
one of them is with a kgb defector which
is going to be fascinating another one
is a special project we did it's a tour
of my house that i just bought you've
been asking for it you'll get that and
then a new show we do about yachts in
fort lauderdale which is absolutely sick
so that's still going to continue all
the other talents going to continue the
podcast is going to continue can't wait
to show you the reveal of the new
podcast set at the new building which is
which is pretty sick when you find out
what room it's in i can't wait for you
to see that anyways all in all
valuetainment wouldn't be where it's at
without you you need to know that i
appreciate you more than you would know
whether it's a call text dms messages
face to face airport traveling europe
south america central america india no
matter where i run into you i love it
when i see the valuetainment logo on
your screen from pvd podcast
valuetainment i just love all of it and
even some of the debates we have i love
all of it this is a great time for you
to also share with us some ideas on what
you'd want to see take place with
vitamin what do what you want to see
more of what you want to see you know
unique episodes more deeper topics what
is it you'd like to see we want to hear
your ideas as well comment below this is
a very good time we're going to debrief
amongst the group and have a lot of
strategy session and come back with a
every time we've done this we're taking
it to the next level and when we do this
again and come back
you're gonna see some of the new
planning we're gonna have where uh where
we're gonna go with this valuetainment
thing so having said that once again i
don't wanna just stop doing motivation
mondays and tuesdays and you're like how
come this guy's not doing it i respect
your time a lot we've stayed steady with
our schedule for the last four years not
missing a single
motivation monday or how to never once
in these years that we've done it have
we missed our schedule so having said
that for some of you that maybe haven't
caught up on a lot of the content that
we've created there's two things that we
have i want you to consider watching one
of them is my favorite
top five interviews i've done in the
last four years that's gonna be the
playlist over here and i think you know
which one's gonna be at the top but you
can find out which one the top five are
it's a good opportunity to go maybe
binge watch some of these interviews if
you haven't caught up on those
interviews yet and the other one is uh
top five how-to's business episodes more
for those of you guys that are on the
business and the things that you want to
grow your business in 2022 and take it
to the next level there's a lot of great
videos from the past that we've shot
click over to watch that episode either
way i appreciate your loyalty appreciate
your love i feel valuetainment has the
best fans of free thinkers big thinkers
that are you know capitalists and
entrepreneurs that want to question uh
the status quo and they want to do
something big and special with their
lives and leave a legacy behind that's
how we connect together when you are
together in a room at a vault conference
and i see everybody talk to each other
the most common thing people tell me is
i can't believe i feel like when i talk
to other people from the valuetainment
community i feel like i'm talking to
somebody myself that fabric that you
have that i have that we have
there's a lot of similarity there so i
respect you a lot i love you guys and
cannot wait to come back and reveal to
you our next plan on what we want to do
with valuetainment having said that
thank you so much for watching and being
great fans take care everybody bye bye
bye bye
all right
you